this is a production of Cornell
University so it's a little bit of an
experimental lecture it's the first time
I'm talking about blockchain and food
security but it's something I started
working my way into about six eight
months ago and the more I looked into it
the more I got absolutely excited and
imagination got going what I want to do
in the next 41 minutes is with 75 slides
so bear with me is to provide you a
broad basic understanding of what
protein is and what it isn't get you
excited with lots of applications that
are growing up everywhere from all
directions and then end up with some
fundamental questions I think that we
will need to we as a society but also I
think a scientists will need to think
about and grapple with so I want to
dispel some myths give you a few
essential elements that I think are
really important to understand
blockchain give you a plethora of
current applications I'll go through
very quickly including on on food
agriculture and so forth and
philanthropy and then as I said some
questions and hopefully we'll have a
good discussion
first of all five myths blockchain is
all about Bitcoin well know Bitcoin
you've heard about it price went up
price crash price goes up again
it's just one application but Bitcoin
when Bitcoin started it has been a
seismic shift in the way computers in
fact can talk to each other and execute
programs and that's what makes this so
exciting
another method is Bitcoin use more
electricity than Denmark that may be not
necessarily a be a myth but the point is
it's not really a prop
because bitcoin is just the first
application and there are already so
many follow-on innovations that are
coming that radically changed a business
model and that loose use very very
little electricity or computing power
for the same transactions I'll give some
examples on that the value of
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin currency
encrypted in the blockchain is
fictitious it's imaginary it has no
relationship to reality well that may be
true but it's basically about the use of
these tokens and I'll come back later to
what their token and the crypto currency
is yes there is a certain truth to that
but there can also be a direct link with
a fiat currency that could be or there
could be a direct link with something
solid something real like your house
just on the value Amazon you wish you
had invested or your parents had
invested even ten dollars only or
hundred dollars and look where it is now
we often forget that many
companies that were completely changing
the paradigm look at the share price at
the dot-com bubble of Amazon well many
people lost complete confidence this is
not going to work this whole well same
with Bitcoin it's gone up it's come down
it's going up again it's absolutely
nothing unusual what we are seeing today
to what we are familiar with
historically with any new paradigm
shifts in technologies Amazon as as an
example of that we also hear that
cryptocurrencies enabled criminal
activities money laundering and so forth
yes they can and yes they are safeguards
that are being implemented for
regulations but nothing unusual you can
take a suitcase of cash and pay somebody
to do something bad for you so it just
makes this easier on the blockchain but
in essence it's nothing unusual about a
tool that you can use for dual purposes
perhaps over time blockchain will be of
cryptocurrencies will be the least
likely wants to be used for criminal
activities but that's the subject that
would take us too far to go into why I
think that is then Satoshi Nakamoto you
may have heard of him he is or her or
she or they are the ones who wrote a
white paper that became Bitcoin a white
paper is to describe the system it was
absolutely a watershed moment in this
area but whoever that person or persons
are we don't know who he is
stood on the shoulders of giants there
were many precursor technologies that
were essential to enable his
groundbreaking or her groundbreaking
invention of Bitcoin and of course
others as you see a theorem hash graph
are becoming almost as if not even more
game-changer than Bitcoin itself so what
is
blockchain I'm using blockchain and
distributed ledger the
ecology sin synonymously they are not
quite necessarily the same they can be
but you hear distributed ledger or
blockchain for all practical purposes
it's the same and it's all about
Ledger's this in fact ancient from Giza
from the Pyramid of Giza it's a list of
items you're familiar with your lab
notebooks that's in fact a ledger the
date what you did what came out of it
how you did it what do you think about
it it's a ledger your bank account a
ledger how much you have how much you
spend where it went
etc in fact it started with your life
when your mother gave birth the hospital
brought down in a ledger the day to time
the name the parents it's a ledger now
if you lose your birth certificate you
have a little problem in future this
will all be on the blockchain you can no
longer lose it so basically that's it
that's the protein it's a legend it's
just distributed on the Internet
sorry distributed across computers so
we're familiar with the centralized
nature of the Internet you go shopping
on amazon.com to take the same example
you go to central Amazon server in the
cloud but still it's an Amazon own
server and transactions happen between
you and a third party and your credit
card
well Amazon is really decentralized now
they have many service cloud service all
over but it's still owned by them what
is this
different with blockchain is distributed
so there's no more central authority
if one of them gets corrupted gets
infected is operated by a criminal gang
or is suddenly inoperative because the
country closes off firewall the system
is resilient and continues happily to
live thereafter up to a certain point
and that's the point and this is the
Byzantine generals problem this alone
would take an hours lecture but in a
nutshell what blockchain does it solves
this particular problem let's assume you
have in this case 2 4 6 8 10 11 generals
with their own armies surrounding
Byzantine city they can't communicate by
radio they're you know 3,000 years ago
that wasn't invented so they have to
send messengers to the others at what
time on what date will we attack and are
you in or not
do you agree and if everybody agrees on
that particular time and date they all
attack and they are bound to take over
the city if that's not the case if one
of them fails or lies or is a spy then
if one general arm if one general or one
army doesn't make it they will all get
killed so how do you solve this problem
when all you can do is send a message to
others that says I'm going to attack do
you agree messenger comes back yes I
agree well you don't know if that
general has been in is lying what about
if that general sends a different
message to somebody else and that's one
of the big problems
in computers databases security since
the invention of the internet in fact
but blockchain or Bitcoin satoshi
nakamoto date solved this problem others
tried before with elements of it but the
real breakthrough was again Bitcoin and
its cryptographically solved
mathematically solved I will leave it at
that at the moment and the point that I
said earlier up to a point is if more
than 1/3 of the generals are spies then
you're out of luck so there's a limit to
how many can be bad guys I mean if
you're not if you're in the city of
course the spy is a good guy but all
practical purposes if you want to attack
you can only do with 1/3 or less that
are bad guys otherwise the system really
doesn't work but that's a fairly
formidable threshold
especially when you have thousands or
hundreds of thousands of computers
around one blockchain then it becomes
pretty nearly impossible not completely
impossible but nearly so that's an
essential concept that has been solved
you just have to take my word for it
now another concept to understand is the
hash so you see these long strings of
numbers and letters that represent
underlying data and many of you in the
DNA sequencing you're familiar with how
do you compare DNA sequences while not
by comparing billions of pairs but by
using hash so a hash is a series of
letters numbers that represents a series
of DNA database in a CG TAC so
the example here is John Smith there is
a hash function and John Smith is 0 2 so
0 2 represents John Smith but you can't
deduct from 0 from knowing 0 2 what that
is John Smith
for that you need two cryptographic keys
and so they can never be a hash that is
identical if there's another John Smith
that John Smith because it's uploaded on
a different time different place gets a
different hash all that is embedded in
the function and so big stuff becomes
much smaller and can be transmitted
through the internet very very fast in
nanoseconds please so there are several
ways of doing this with public and
private keys some of you may be familiar
with that if you have an RSA stake or so
but yes there's a direct function
because the 0 to cannot represent
anything else but John Smith but you
need the entire key the public in the
private to come back to that hence this
is one layer of security which makes
blockchain enormous Li hacker-proof
so far there have been no hacks of
exchanges yes but that's different to
the blockchain itself having been acted
so there's no known hacking that has yet
occurred and not likely to occur in the
near future something else to understand
very briefly is the consensus how do all
these nodes all these computers come to
consensus think of it a following way
give birth to John Smith in the hospital
that gets into the ledger and then
distributed to all the computers and
that John Smith gets a hash how do all
the computers the thousands or hundreds
of thousands computers agree that this
is really the right hash for this John
Smith well either the computers do some
proof of work a lot of computations
mathematical computation hence our
consumption or there is a proof of stake
where if they have a certain stake in a
particular platform they are the ones
that solve it that solve certain
mathematical cryptographic problems and
then validate that yes this entry is the
right one and everybody didn't agrees
that this is a knows that this is the
only strong Smith born by these parents
in that hospital at that time because
when you have databases especially when
they are distributed you can't have one
that is slightly different to the other
those who you share point here Cornell
to upload your your data you sometimes
you have synchronization errors that's
really the issue here and again the
blockchain solves by making it
impossible that is an in synchronization
error next one is what I mentioned over
lunch with the students there are two
types of block chains and I'm soon
ending with the key concepts one is
permissionless so you can use it you
don't need any accreditation you can buy
bitcoins trade with bitcoins doesn't
matter and there are lots of permission
ones where you need an account you need
to be accredited you need to be allowed
to use it you need to abide by the rules
and if not you're thrown out or pay
penalties and so forth so these two
systems are
both can exist he theorem is in fact
both depending on the application and
the state of the technology is maybe
early 90s mid-90s when the world wide
web just started many of you weren't
born by that time you have no idea how
life was before the internet we had to
go to an actual library and look up
cards and go and look for books to get
information so we are early in that
development and who knows what the
future holds and that's part of the
fascinating thing about it what the
future could hold the last concept is
smart contracts so smart contracts are
nothing else but an algorithm again a
what-if then function a computer program
that says if I sell you through a
blockchain a book you give me bitcoins
or whatever and let's say it's a
permissioned application where we both
are we may not know who you are
who each other is but we are on that
blockchain on that application and if
you don't upload within and say 24 hours
proof of shipment of the book that I
bought or that I whichever way around
then the smart contract says oh he did
not upload on time therefore he is going
to refund twice the amount that he on
one plate that's a simple what if
function and so you can embed those
functions and dispute resolution
everything can be written in code that
accompanies certain transactions just
think of
buying a house how long does it take a
couple of months to put money in escrow
you get title search you get documents
certified by lawyers a mortgage pay down
this and that it takes ages and meetings
and lots of money goes to lots of
middlemen and middle women sorry well
with blockchain and the first houses
have been sold on a blockchain this is
automated it takes a couple of hours of
course somebody has to upload the title
and certify that the original title that
was uploaded on the blockchain is
authentic
so that first step needs to be done once
but if there's a lien on the house if
there's a mortgage if there's something
wrong with it it's all on the blockchain
can be verified by the buyer and if
something were wrong the smart contract
would then take care of some penalties
in whatever way that particular
blockchain has written the code so it
takes a couple of minutes or a couple of
hours and all is automatic obviously not
everybody likes this but Amazon wasn't
liked by bookstores and it changes the
world so it's not whether or not it's
liked but how fast will new minds you
come up with new applications like
incline reading for example that may
make certain technologies that we know
today completely obsolete so a couple of
minutes a couple of seconds on summary
it's decentralized that's the key and
trusted so you don't need to trust a
particular computer or particular player
but you the system is the one that gives
trust you have trust in your credit card
bank bank today should your credit card
you put your money there you have trust
implicit well this is now done online
where this did not exist before
blockchain okay how does it work very
briefly you have a smartphone for
example you request a transaction it
goes into that cyberspace there with
these computers doing their number
crunching they all come up with a
consensus remember different ways there
many different ways of consensus I only
gave to proof of state proof of work and
then in the end it's a proof transaction
it goes into the block and it's there
forever it can never ever be changed
again so it's tamper proof you can't
later change and change forger document
and you get confirmation the other
person gets confirmation on their smart
phone within minutes or seconds
depending on the system you use very
last concept to briefly touch on is I
used words coins tokens and
cryptocurrencies so far it's actually
the difference but actually very very
difficult in practice because there's so
much overlap of the two concepts coins
or cryptocurrencies are money it's money
in the cyberspace that may or may not
relate to something real dollars or
houses and tokens tokens are more used
in permission chains for transactions
and most tokens have to be purchased
with coins I think in one minute that's
as good definition I can give off the
two for practical purposes think of the
coins more like money and the tokens
more like fudge double fungible ways of
transacting things your AIA airline
miles
it's fungible so you may get it token in
the future and you can use it for
airline miles or to buy flowers for your
loved ones so where do we stand today I
said it's really early but we're already
in the version five probably of
blockchain depending on whom you agree
with whom you agree I think Bitcoin got
the whole financial industry FinTech
really going he theorem a twenty year
old guy started that with smart
contracts it's not the most ubiquitous
way of doing rock chains the apps I
won't touch on it today it has now seen
early industrial use applications and lo
and behold new technologies I invented
hash graph that may once again
revolutionize I won't dwell into it but
I can strongly urge you to look at this
description by the inventor of it it's
an absolutely beautiful
new type of blockchain if you want
Ashcraft it's not quite blockchain the
difference is Bitcoin you have a couple
of thousand transactions every five to
ten minutes with hash graph you can have
250,000 and more per second and then you
can layer them and have 500,000 1
million and million transaction per
second so think of these are processing
your credit card processing all of that
it's already being developed by hash
graph by swear all the company for visa
in order they have hundreds of thousands
of transactions a second where this will
all eventually be done paperless on the
blockchain the terminals in the shop you
won't even notice the difference you may
want they just put your smartphone there
as you do with wallet pay Apple pay and
it will all be done by a blockchain so
let's move on to current 23 minutes and
I might Wow one minute ahead of time not
bad so we'll get through this 75 slides
don't worry because the next ones will
be very fast so these are the different
areas I'm going to cover very quickly
row on the left and then spend a bit
more time on the food production and
food distribution so where can you buy
stuff using crypto currencies of coins
or old coins old coins by the way are
normally referring to not being Bitcoin
well these are just some examples and
there hundreds more you can buy pizza
you can buy beer you can buy a flight
into space on Virgin Galactic the
Bitcoin or crypto currencies and I will
talk about open Bazaar in a minute but
the first one I want to show is whistle
and I'm from Switzerland so you can
already buy rail tickets using Bitcoin
the ID you see the ID here that's all
you need if your application you take
the photograph like a barcode just the
ID and you buy your train
take it with Bitcoin and that already
exists since 2016 so we are quite ahead
of time actually I find this pretty neat
open Bazaar was on my list open Bazaar
is something a permission block chain I
won't say this anymore because most of
the implications are you set up an
account you get accredited you buy
tokens and I now sell my book on open
Bazaar somebody on the other side of the
world can buy them no transaction fees
with foreign currencies nothing in the
way I described earlier with the book
there is a way of doing that seamlessly
this could potentially disrupt Amazon's
business model
Amazon when I sell a book on Amazon and
I'm selling some an on through a
non-profit they take forty five percent
of the sale price and if your company
takes fifty five percent well here it'd
be a fraction of that I think the
biggest applications today industrial
scale is in the supply chain supply
chain management that are enormous ly
cumbersome just think of shipping
Microsoft and mask are have developed
already a prototype where all the
documentation for insurance for
cross-border for destinations content
taxation everything is on the blockchain
everything is executed automatically the
container arrives in the port scan the
truck loads it scan goes through custom
scan ends up in Walmart scan you buy it
scan and that's it
an example of some insurance companies
in Asia try it across eight
jurisdictions if you have insurance
across countries
its enormous lis paper and regulatory
intensive and so many checks and
double-checks and putting in the into a
database and another company a different
database and it takes about four months
to settle an insurance claim between
Hong Kong and the Philippines
so they sure in Hong Kong issues and a
policy to accompany in the Philippines
if there's an incident takes four months
with that blockchain a prototype that
they did it took four hours
quite a few people will lose their jobs
those that have to check and put paper
in photocopy scan classify and so forth
the benefit is of course that everything
will be faster and essentially foolproof
or as foolproof as the blockchains
applications one of the most advanced is
ever ledger for diamonds so from the
point of mining photographed all the way
to the sale on your wedding ring
all on blockchain there are millions of
diamonds already if they're cut that
gets on it that gets recorded in a
blockchain and just a few numbers on
fraud prevention 45 billion estimated in
the diamond industry to be lost to fraud
most of that can be prevented with
blockchain most fraudulent claims go
undetected
and I rest my case there so in future
you'll buy the wedding ring diamond you
will know the minor you'll see the face
on your phone on your smartphone you
will know that it's not a blood diamonds
distributed cloud storage another
application
you can rent out your computer your
laptop for others to store their files
if you have space left and make some
money along that way you can't read
again encrypted cryptographically
essentially foolproof its Turin
that are familiar with BitTorrent
similar system to be torrent so the same
is in many different computers if one is
down you still have access to your files
here's what FinTech the I think the
conclusion on FinTech is somebody from
Berkeley high up our belief at Barclays
is that blockchain is a fundamental part
of the new operating system for the
planet so when you hear that central
banks and banks are against Bitcoin and
blockchain well yes until they figured
out that they could probably benefit
from it as well this will fundamentally
transform our way of interacting with
each other at every level of life our k
city will take over Eva maybe one day
uber takes quite a cut central authority
again Arcade City you have drivers you
me again permission blockchain and a
fraction of the cost to me or to you the
rider
will completely change the way we do
transport that's just for taxi type of
transports think of parcels think of
distribution of the postal system
mind-boggling if you just dare to think
of the potential implications renting
it's just finished it's ico
rent Berry that's for long-term rentals
Airbnb will be history maybe one day
let's look at some medical applications
and broses tracking the origin of the
medicines all the way to bedside from
bench from production to bedside think
of what it means for vaccines where
every storage has been monitored was it
too long at room temperature etc
fraudulent medicines fakes and so forth
a tremendous technology to all but
eliminate it completely
another medical application is or health
research application is a professor at
MIT just started recently a block chain
where you put up your DNA every
sequenced gets on the blockchain and if
companies come and steal your DNA or
compare or fish out certain sequences
you actually get paid per view so to
speak with tokens Jim managing medical
records it's just one of many that are
already starting this
revolutionize the health industry just
that fact alone and then imagine what
you could do if you superimpose AI
artificial intelligence machine learning
having access to some of those medical
records
you get tokens by the way if they
pay-per-view along the way they don't
know who you are but now suddenly you
have everybody who's on that blockchain
the medical records could now be mined
for science a new world you can pay
casinos now you can gamble with on the
blockchain with an advantage it's not
stacked against you you go to gamble
it's always stacked against you yards
the house always wins at the end of the
day not here it's zero that's why the
zero coin they still make a little bit
of money with the transactions and
that's it so it's fair gambling
III don't suggest you try it out I'm
just giving you examples but you can
then think further what this could mean
for democracy
think about that when you walk home okay
governments that brings me to
government's just a few dubai they want
to get the whole state everything on
blockchain Estonia all public records
you identities on blockchain South Korea
all the transportation will be on
managed on blockchain the UK is still
studying whether they should do pensions
payments of pensions again fraud
prevention and then you have other
interesting applications voting one day
will be on the blockchain inevitable and
guess what
two days ago Arizona passed a bill to
allow tax payments with Bitcoin and this
is not a hose so one day here's what
will happen you will buy something at
Green Star Wegmans it will already the
blockchain for which you bought it will
deduct all the right taxes instantly
almost transfer the taxes to the right
players
your income from Cornell or from
wherever will come through the
blockchain and the smart contracts
associated with the blockchain
will know how much taxes you are owed to
pay to whom I when will all be automated
HR block goodbye let's go into some fun
stuff
philanthropy bit give look it up it's a
way to know exactly what you're giving
where it ended up with to whom by when
at what time crowdfunding on the
blockchain Kickstarter is history this
will be the future this developed by the
Gates Foundation Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation to enable the to point some
billion people that are non not banking
to have wallets and be able to actually
have money in their pockets and not to
have to walk to another village with
cash for a transaction so it's to
empower the poor let's come to some
agricultural applications and there's so
many I didn't know which ones to choose
I'm selected a few random ones some for
fun some because I think they are
groundbreaking in their technologies
this one I've put first because I'm
still trying to get my head around what
exactly their business model is but it
looks done promising that's all I can
say this one is a bit more advanced from
the Netherlands out of offering you can
when you go to Green Star you can know
exactly the provenance of each
individual honey of course you can also
use it for whiskey
I know which island which I'll a which
farmer milled it awry and all that and
weight was distilled you will all see
that on the blockchain one day this
probably is another one that is really
neat permissioned of course you need to
have an account but what they do is they
already have certain certifications that
they provide its audited and so forth it
will reduce the cost of producing as
certified let's say organic trademarked
products where you have collective marks
for quality this will be the only way
things will be sold in the future think
of it for developing country suddenly
it's becoming easier for a developing
country farmer to participate because
the transaction costs here are minuscule
compared to what they used to be using
banks and shippers and importers and
exporters and storage and so forth all
the middle men block grain in Australia
where payments are happening almost
instantaneously again on quality a
variant of the above be Fletcher you
know it will be fine I don't know what
it means because but what's-his-face
there will be vegan and I did when I
googled and try to find vegan
blockchains I couldn't find any except
one that didn't take off but I found an
interesting blog and the title was
cryptocurrencies are turning me vegan I
just thought it was fun
a couple of more minutes global cannabis
chain here you see all the different
functions that this chain is integrating
taxation of course as well profit
fishermen in Indonesia you buy you eat
you order fish on the plate tonight for
dinner on the menu is the barcode you
scan it you see the fishermen you see
the route he or she took when it was
fished how it was transported how much
the fishermen got every stage you know
how much they got paid and if you want
you add a tip for the fishermen at the
end of your meal if the fish was good
seriously and that provenance has it now
in in many different sectors so it's all
about tracing verification and Trust
they claim to be the blockchain of food
as I'm saying there are many of those
starting many will fail some will become
the ubiquitous Amazons calm and one day
the question will be how will the
different block chains interrupt what is
the interoperability of the different
block chains and the inventor of a
theorem is writing a white paper as we
speak and promises to come up with a
solution just to stretch your mind a
little bit more Monsanto paid over a
billion dollars for climate calm climate
data now think of integrating that
information with artificial intelligence
machine learning and blockchain I'm just
putting that out to stretch your minds
this is why Monsanto bought paid a
billion dollars for the data and then
there are lots on IP but that would be a
subject for another talk let's come back
to a few forward-looking questions what
is the future price of Bitcoin I don't
know all I can say is now is a good time
to sell and I'll buy them
ok joke apart what does the future hold
at the interface of distributed ledger
technology or blockchain and artificial
intelligence I valued it to it a few
times
just think of breeding phenotype
screening putting all that stuff on
blockchain and having a wheat breeder at
the other side of the world and
artificial intelligence that makes sense
of all that data that comes together
that no longer sits in
god knows what different databases and
singers and singer whatever it's called
and I know if that still exists
diversity
trust what is it called for the DNA all
of that will be on blockchain and with
artificial intelligence it will
revolutionize breeding like I think
molecular genetics has done by when will
blockchain make Airbnb and uber obsolete
I think the writing is on the wall will
block trade applications be regulated as
public goods they have the quality of a
perfect public good non-rival rain
consumption and non-excludable at least
they're not the permissionless so that
alone would be a couple of hours to
discuss or will blockchain enable an
Orwellian future where the government
controls everything from your birth
certificate to your income to your taxes
to your transportation you can't
transport unless you have a part of a
blockchain and if for some reason they
don't like you or think you should be
incarcerated they turn off the switch
and you can't move anymore
so the very technology Bitcoin that was
supposed to be completely decentralized
make governments and central banks
obsolete and take away their power could
one day be turn against them just
putting out food for thought and of
course the question for the discussion
forty-two minutes exactly can we harness
our institutions your minds to actually
use blockchain for all the good
applications bring different values
different cultures together around a
system that we can all understand
address the sustainable development
goals of the United Nations
that's for evening lecture a summary of
the benefits I just want to spend 30
seconds on the last one on governance
with two examples one is what is the
parallel to the executive its the nodes
the judiciary is the miners that make
sure that come to consensus the
legislature is in fact the system that
was built the platform itself and then
we have all the users but you also have
fundamental questions how blockchain is
going to fundamentally change the
governance of corporations because it
changes the power structure and who has
power this professor by the way New York
University is fantastic one of the world
authorities on economics
and that's it here's a farmer sweet
potato farmer in the Red River Delta in
outside Hanoi I haven't asked her what
she thinks of blockchain
but that's worth a discussion
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah like everything related to your
house yeah the builders the materials
that were used in the building in the
construction the paint's when it was
renovated everything
but-but-but-but that's real actually
that application exists today and has
been solved and it's been solved by you
don't need to transact transfer all the
information all the time that's how it's
solved right so you have to not much
it's nanoseconds couple of packs and
fourths well
bitcoin is is what ten twelve megabytes
per block a theorem makes transactions
much faster hash graph is front
kilobytes for the same amount where what
you need to transfer all the time is
proof that you are who you claim you are
and that you want to execute a certain
transaction that is a certain specified
and allowed transaction and that the
system then allows you to do the
transaction and transfer ownership title
or whatever it is that's where the
transactions take place their underlying
data you don't need to transfer all the
time
yes because you have it transferred once
and it's there once the first time
that's why the blockchain is immutable
unchangeable once it's in a block is
unchangeable then that's it
it stays there look at all the data
sense centers of amazon.com again to
pick on Amazon yeah I mean tetra bytes
or flops I don't even know what the
terminology is for the amount of storage
how much data goes across every
nanosecond this is not a problem no no
the energy goes into useless
mathematical processing actually for the
Bitcoin because you have it centralized
with block chain you will use less
energy to do the same function but it'll
be transferred once and then it's
locally among computer and you can
access it it's immutable it's it's
associated with a particular code or
hash and when I looked up that hash I
can see what I want to see and get that
from the blockchain I don't need to get
it from all the million computers only
one
other questions I hope you guys will
come up with those answers and your
minds will solve that well I think the
Mojo the one that I mentioned from Gates
Foundation which they developed three
years ago by the way or four is in ten
in fact intended to enable to develop
the infrastructure needed precisely to
connect those yeah I'm not sure how
immediate its relative of course but I
mean it takes us to another subject
which is what is the limit of democracy
these two are very closely related what
do the people what do we allow our
governments to actually do so the same
blockchain can be used either to curb
that power and make it really democratic
or to bring that ovarian future and the
choice will be ours
so there was one slide on food safety
the cost of false meat for example
recalls with blockchain because you know
the provenance and every step and
wherever it was you can't just add 50
more pounds because that will be locked
at the point of origin but yes you can
cheat but you will be on a permission
blockchain so you will have to have been
accredited to use it and if you play bad
once there will be consequences
so is it completely foolproof no but
take the diamond you take the picture of
the diamond once that picture and
assuming it's not from a blood blood
diamond but taken from somewhere else
and then photographed here those things
are always possible but I think the
blockchain reduces and the accreditation
and the auditing that will go with it
that goes with it it reduces that
potential significantly it's not
completely it doesn't eliminate it
doesn't put everybody doesn't make
everybody honest overnight anymore
question
can contact me here and just for my own
honesty credits of some of the images I
downloaded from this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu